hi carlos good morning hey tom good to
see you how are you today
yeah very good thank you i hope we
haven't got you up too early on the
other side of the
of the atlantic no no no we're good
we're good
okay you know you um one of the things i
love
when i watch you in interview shows and
talk shows is your impressions you have
a great owen wilson impression
even going so far as to do owen wilson
as loki did you ever do this for owen
wilson
while you were shooting i i was i mean
it was i think it was a long time ago
and um somebody i was in sydney and
somebody asked me to
do a number of um different iterations
of loki's lines in
in the voices of other people but but we
you know kind of
mentioned in passing but um yeah
[Music]
is it is it a good or bad idea to do an
impression of a co-star
to their face i don't know i mean i i
probably over
over the course of uh over the course of
my life i'm i'm almost certain that i
i uh you know in a spirit of kind of
of of playfulness i have i've done that
i know i've definitely done it with uh
i think chris hemsworth and i once did
impressions of each other
on the set of four but yeah um
owen is is owen is amazing though
um and he
i i think you've seen have you seen the
first two
yes yeah yeah so you know he's such a
he's such an amazing performer and i
what i love about him and this is
he's quite different to how
audiences have seen him before maybe
it's a slightly different
he looks slightly different and he did a
lot of work in
in presenting a different exterior with
you know with
a different hairstyle and a and a
moustache and
um i love what he's done with mobius i
can't wait for people to see him
in this i like that um
that little bit you were talking about
your relationship with you and chris you
know that
audition for thor where you were
auditioning to play thor
many moons ago i like to think of as a
bit of a nexus event you ever think
about
what the how the timeline splits there
and what that other
version of tom might be doing today
yeah i mean it is definitely chris and i
talked about it like that
that moment of being cast as thor and
loki have changed
you know completely changed our lives
and
um i don't i can't imagine now because
it's been so long
um where i would be or what i would be
doing
if that hadn't happened um
and uh what he would be doing i mean we
talked about it a lot and felt very
at the time felt very grateful um
and it kind of it was the thing that
kind of uh forged our
friendship was we were kind of buckled
into this roller coaster ride
together at the same time as quite young
men
and we didn't know where we were going
but we were just kind of holding on for
the ride and
and um yeah that's i guess that's the
nature of time is
things happen and they change stuff so
yeah it would be it would be i i don't
know that the world would be that
different but my life would probably be
that different yeah for sure
well man i gotta say we've been what's
your next event
do you think what my nexus event yeah
i i've got two kids i gotta say it's the
birth of the first
one right yeah yeah that changes
everything this is everything
but that's i mean that's one of the
wonderful things one
but i mean before i go really quickly
because i got to get out of here but one
of the wonderful things about the show
is that albans
it's fun and it's loki and it's marvel
but it opens up all those questions for
you too man
it's really good so far i'm really
enjoying it it's uh it's a film it's a
series about
it asks questions of all of us i think
about
our relationship to time our
relationship to the past our
relationship to the future
you know perhaps we do we have any
agency over the
choices we make or are those choices
somehow
have they been made for us are we active
in those things are we passive
you know it's really clear and how we
kind of to tell the story of ourselves
to ourselves in order to construct a
a identity and how how robust is that
identity like you could
kind of um deconstruct it and maybe it
would all fall apart
i don't know these are good good
questions you made me think about it
you